[Music]
all right as we showed you last night
Democrats radical extremism hit a new
level one 20/20 hopeful Bernie Sanders
made the shocking admission so yeah
felons including the sarna brothers
terrorists pedophiles murderers oh they
should be allowed to vote no president
Trump's re-election campaign responded
to these outrageous comments calling it
deeply offensive and some more
embarrassing comments from Sanders and
now resurfacing oh look at this 1971
Sanders harshly criticized get this
millionaire Senators he said they're
immoral he's a millionaire senator why
would he say that about himself I wonder
if Bernie stands by that today
now Sanders will soon have more company
in the already crowded 2020 race matter
of fact hours away from creepy crazy
uncle jill biden expected to throw his
hat into the ring but the former vp is
already facing a possible setback
according to sources obama oh who he
served under for eight years won't
endorse him or any 2020 candidate early
in the race a lot of confidence in you
Joe joining us now with reaction senior
advisor for Donald Trump for president
that would be president Trump's
daughter-in-law Lara Trump how are you
good to see you I'm great you've been
busy
of course we've all been busy Shawn I
know all right so do you have a
preference I think actually Biden would
be perfect because Fighting's not gonna
have to answer by the time 2020 comes
around everything that happened under
their watch he's gonna answer for their
crappy economy and 13 million more
Americans on food stamps 8 million more
poverty then the question is are you
better off than you were four years ago
yep listen people it doesn't matter
Shawn who this president is running
against I always say that I think he's
going to win easily first of all let's
let Joe Biden get in the race he's been
saying for months now that he's gonna
get in the race it hasn't happened yet
we will see tomorrow if it happens but
he's certainly right now seems to look
the most sane out of the candidates that
we've seen the 20 candidates now that
we've seen throw their hat in the ring
for 2020 that that's for sure and that's
saying a lot listen he still has to
defend the things were going to learn
about abuse of power
corruption attorney-general bar used the
word spying on the trunk area there's
stefan halper was recruited to talk to
Papadopoulos and Carter Paige and Sam
Clovis and of course the dirty dossier
the new york times are saying oh that
might have been a disinformation
propaganda thing that hillary bought and
was used to influence the campaign and
backdoor
the president's election I think there's
a lot that the Obama White House and the
Obama administration is gonna have to
answer to when it comes to all the
background on this and and hopefully for
the good of our country we really find
out how this all started and we get to
the bottom of it it doesn't look good
our Attorney General said that there was
spying on our campaign in 2016 but
listen again at the end of the day if
Joe Biden gets in the race let's even
see if he makes it the the number of
candidates that are so radically far
left now in this field is unbelievable
so I don't know maybe Joe Biden doesn't
stand a chance maybe they're looking for
some somebody that's so far outside of
the norm which is crazy to me because I
don't think the American people are
gonna get behind and you don't support a
70% marginal tax rate for individuals 90
percent marginal tax rate for
individuals no oil no gas no combustion
airplanes no cows or cows off noses and
everything all this stuff is so crazy
and then you have as you were just
talking about Bernie Sanders suggesting
that's someone that would use an event
that is such a tradition in America like
the Boston Marathon too as an
opportunity to maim and murder scores of
people including children Sean and the
these individuals should be allotted a
right to vote are you kidding me it's
crazy that we're even talking about that
all right so I have had I had I remember
one day being mad at the president the
day he becomes president makes the caja
lets bygones be bygones forget about
will leave Hillary alone you know what
her okay we hear Hillary today I thought
then it was a mistake and I don't think
he's thinking that anymore you see this
is the FBI investigation Nunez report
house Intel bipartisan Senate now Muller
no collusion no obstruction and still
they
cannot control themselves Media or
Democrats that to me helps you oh of
course it helps us I mean everybody on
the left is so unhinged that there
wasn't anything in the molar report now
it's finally out now we can finally take
a look at it and again as we've all said
from the beginning no collusion that
there's nothing that this president has
done wrong but look at all he's
accomplished on despite the fact that
they have tried every single day to say
that he did something wrong that our
campaign did something wrong they fight
him every day they resist him every day
they obstruct everything he wants to do
all the time and you have this country
right now under this president is the
most successful that it has been in
decades what is it we have an
announcement coming up after the show
it's coming up and later in the show not
after this I thought it was gonna be
that I'm pregnant oh I didn't know if I
could say that that's the Builder begin
the congratulations thank you
now do you know yet boy girl do you or
your little boy is so he's big and he's
really handsome he's big he'll be a
great big brother whatever it is
whatever okay alright should we take
bets about that yeah maybe you should
tell me congratulations happy healthy as
all as the most important the president
has an incredible capacity to
compartmentalize not even though he's
fighting and dealing two plus years with
this but then to fight for all the
things he promised the one thing that a
politician usually doesn't do is keep
their promises but even the border you
name the issue justices that he appoints
the biggest tax cuts ending regulation
energy independence still fighting to
get rid of all of Obamacare thanks well
you you look even at our rally Sean
we've had since the very beginning of
the campaign in 2015 even promises made
promises kept and this is finally a
president that actually means that not
the all talk no action politicians of
the past this is a president that has
delivered on every single promise he
made to the American people and that's
what we're running on in 2020 was this
all hard for you the family how behind
the scenes the two years non-stop which
I it never feels good when people
suggest that you did something wrong and
you know you
and for the president for everyone that
worked on this campaign and we worked
our hearts out on this campaign it was
unlike anything I've ever been a part of
and I feel so honored a big part of it
to have done it of course it doesn't
feel good but we all knew that the truth
would come out one day
sadly you still have people who are
trying to find something wrong that any
of us did they won't find it they can
they can keep looking it's time you were
here I said to you if you cured cancer
and gave every American five million
dollars and adopted their stupid agenda
they still hate him that's true Congrats
on the baby great news great news all
right